it just might not even start is it okay
to cry here we go
okay I thought it wasn't gonna start
there's a little over a hundred players
this is the Cube fanatics here we go I
will be getting older midway through
this tournament
midway through the tournament I would be
a little bit older
there should be three let's get the F oh
that's a free piece oh my goodness just
like that oh my goodness Oh stupid that
was the freest piece you're ever gonna
see okay let's take this he's another
free piece well what's the scoop with
that what's the scoop with that
kitchen-sink variation oh my goodness
what is this cleanup - she's got to go
she's gotta go I can't deal with her oh
my goodness let's do this my queen is
around oh my goodness I could have taken
that rook are you kidding me there's so
many free pieces that I could have been
taken rook takes Knight is there
actually clinking up the bishop at the
end of it I only have 14 seconds I
deserve to lose this I deserve to lose
this 37 seconds for my opponent 14 for
me oh my goodness
could've swore this guy started out the
game sand I wonder how many free pieces
he's gonna miss taking Wow three or four
we're only 16 moves in okay my opponents
not moving they teasing me now what are
you doing Oh another free piece let's
see feels let's see if you'll find that
one they said time is even get these
ladies off man finally pieces for
everyone
take a night get that get that King look
up and over there's no time
rook up and then over I could take the
night with the check his pawn is pinned
here no matter what
back to tournament oh my goodness that
was the longest game ever oh you don't
take free pieces feels like an eternity
you just keep thinking about uh what
what I didn't do my opponent was
anticipating oh he plays he plays c5 all
the time I'll start out with b4 I'll fix
some I got the bishop for me maybe take
this uh oh I can get the Queenie watch
out
tricky Knight land what does that even
mean I'm on the rook I could take this
night and I hear I hear is good isn't it
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna post up on the
dark squares and get my tricky Knight
into the dark f2 night here complete my
development okay
Queen trade love it love the Queen
trades this Knight is now a thorn he's a
giant thorn he's a giant thorn and then
stop this advance very nice no I she's
just taking it we're gonna repeat no
where's my neck even going he's clueless
he is a clueless clueless piece okay I
have a plan
Knight right here that's where he
belongs this baby sit upon for second
okay not my knight could maybe do
something dangerous pawn push next
tricky Knight c3 let's give a check
first and come back just for fun come
over here I'll come back at some more
checks in ok pawn push next
get that rook did another one jump here
they don't have any time Forks trades
here no matter what this game is not
gonna end
back to tournament Wow
Twenty twenty twelve twelve striker this
guy's he's at negative 2 there's Knight
takes pawn there keep that in mind
keep that in mind okay now there's not
going to be that I was wonderful
commentary there's not gonna be that
there's not gonna be that oh really oh
really
Bishop takes I think Knight g4 with
Queen somewhere would have been good
Queen g5 that's what I meant Bishop
takes Bishop with Queens Bishop takes
Bishop Knight g4 Queen g5 stuff I think
was available okay let's get on the only
open file I want to be able to control
this maintain control back rank stuff
flight square I think rook up was
intended let's get ready to defend stuff
King position
okay I have to keep pressure on this
Queen here should have been played I
think a little bit sooner
okay let's check chase the Queen away
from this and then take this pawn I
think I could do this and be safe
watch out for these um when I watching
out for my King has to run around like
crazy I don't want to have to do that
but don't get mated whatever happens
don't get made it oh my god Abel's got
made it I was gonna go here I would have
screamed I would have screamed okay stay
around defend stuff take my queen oh
they're getting the pond oh no no no no
this is bad good bad news King here i'ma
check Oh get the Queen I don't have any
time two seconds I could get a past
prawn over here why was I doing that
what am i doing it like this get this
pawn going oh my goodness the counter
time I had point three seconds oh I
couldn't take that Queen I'd love to
take a Queens but I couldn't take that
Queen how many mouse lips do they have
okay stay focused stay focused now
oh my Queens gonna get beating no she's
not
I think takes in the night somewhere
Knight c3 I've been saying somewhere a
lot and you do um think a bit more
clearly okay let's take that guy I'm on
the dark scrub I mom is pollen twice
they could have taken this okay he's got
to go let's castle break down this
actually yeah let's open up stuff
against their Queen Queen trade
Pond push is good to open up the H file
I'll do this I think okay now let's get
out of that any pawn push I meet with
the pawn push and I keep the gene H
files closed there might be some sack
here or that which is extremely scary
this is this is a sensitive point I get
that Bishop out of there much time I
should've just done this right away yeah
I know it's coming
I gotta do this yep how to do that this
pawn is falling gotta get this in a
tricky tricky night oh my goodness
oh my goodness okay could I break this
open on the rook give checks give a
knight check oh that's got to be scary
the king is homeless thank you so much
give me a check umm oh this is working
out this has to be good right yeah let
me check where's that mate oh I think
here's me no I just dropped my queen oh
my goodness oh my goodness is this okay
I'm gonna get check time dinars where
oh my goodness
they're down on time oh that's all like
that's my best friend
who's your best friend let me know tell
me right now time time is my best friend
free pieces are my best friend as well a
mouse slip oh my goodness you would
think I'm doing this on purpose I'm
really not mouse slips free pieces
everywhere that I don't take Oh time
time time time get on open files would
you please
oh I don't want to make a pond of that
night is scary over here g4 h5 stuff
that's come all the way home
Bishop III to g1 a my queen up here
first my opponent has trouble developing
don't material now I'm gonna get this
pun as well I have three people on it
three people three people on it three
pieces the big question here is what who
who is gonna be the MVP that's what
everybody wants to know who's gonna be
the MVP this game Queen d2 this knight
is pinned and VP the most valuable piece
right
this night is still pinned you can't
move he did move the rook is hit the
knight is hit I'm winning material and
night here converging on f7 next twenty
seconds next twenty seconds left
Queenie seven next
14 let's check tonight here meeting to
threat f7 h7 difficult to defend rook
takes Bishop I guess still on me takes
f7 here no matter what
it's game h8 rh6 back to tournament 30
somebody has 90 Wow 90 56:42 34 30 my
goodness what is that player eaten what
is he eating
what is he eating is what everybody in
this tournament wants to know okay I
need to get a quick win this is a quick
pun do that no matter what there's no
block in defense of e5 so I'm up upon
and now I'm gonna be saddling white with
an isolated epon and I think wiped as
well to get the Queen's off the board my
queen is a fantastic on that square
let's get some center I'm not even
considering castling kingside and the
pressure on the heart b2 I want to trade
light square bishop well let's close
things up ideal placement for my pawns
works well with my works well with what
okay I could defend let's kick this
Knight out of their night here
okay let's watch over that I want to
just take the night and then play night
here okay no I'm just stopping the night
from doing what okay let's develop on
push here is my next break
this night is out of play let's jump in
here on the rook soon reserve that let's
get this in no need to go there just yet
it's a good jumping point alright let's
break this down break this down the
Knights gonna take a post here I have
this watched over though c2 is hit have
this defendant tricky night double rooks
less than 10 seconds here no matter what
I got to go I have to go
less than three anything anything at all
this game is not gonna end back to turn
at 42 110 110 56 54 48 whoa d4 back to
tournament quick resigning who was that
that just resigned
are they resigning to other people okay
they resigning to that top guy as well
c5 that's a lot of games to be in right
10 games how many do I have seven oh
this guy's not starting he's at negative
26 16 minutes remaining in this
tournament double the points got this
one as well back-to-back wins 6556 110
10 games in we have that highest score
that's crazy it's crazy high okay no
night chief will stop out Knight g4
stuff defend oh my goodness Oh what am I
gonna learn my lesson and disable the
right mouse-click
when will I learn when will I ever learn
all right this is trouble now I'm gonna
open it what am I gonna do I want to
give up material and then jump into h6
where's that mate
no way no way not buying it this is
check and then nein no I mean I get
material at a ton of material not here
or look here let me just defend for a
little bit my nights there to block he
defends of tongue we take here
discovered tricks Oh Queen takes Queen
alright this is still good
my opponent basically cannot move 20
seconds you no matter what here no
matter what trades see the last piece
that can move for my opponent they
resigned back to tournament 83 150 83
wow it's like catchable Oh an air I get
any points for that 150 93 okay II for
14 we're at the halfway about the
halfway point French what kind of French
okay Fort Knox Bishop d7 I miss dropped
a piece maybe I could get the Queen no
she's on f6 Bishop d3 Bishop d3 and then
Bishop g5 would be winning the Queen
alright queenside castle how do they get
their Queen oh maybe they give me the H
file and I could target the isolated
pawns okay let's get castled my bishop
out there Brooke his opposite might
clean there might be a pawn break let's
come over with this rook I don't want to
take this truck off the h-file Queen
trade this is a good rule
I was a nice move this Bishop was
unprotected very nice
okay isolated pond now the tables turn I
think I should still be good no okay
well yeah I'm still good here I have to
defend stuff though at the end of it I
could get this pawn this is still
favorable get one rook off and then take
him he's packed no I don't have a passed
pawn because of that capture let's get
more trades in though I'm reluctant to
play this because of Bishop b3 alright
let's get my king position in and let's
get this move in that King out of there
King position I have a three and maybe
some stuff over here King hears me yes
that's exactly what I needed one
thirteen 171 thirteen thirteen games in
and I still have to make up 60 about 60
points alright let's take over the
center maybe or gain some tempo I should
be saying okay this is still protected
can't take here because of Bishop checks
wow they missed it Bishop check they
might resign Lina resign no
counter-attack
I'm gonna take that and Bishop check and
then clean out here no matter what if
Knight takes like pin all right here and
then here no matter what night here I'll
just kick it get rid of this night
otherwise I get this pawn and if rook c1
I play b5 King position King position
again get on the C file and I hear
they're in a pin if they move
take this pond next the Knights there
create a passed pawn let's get rolling
get my rook right behind it keep pushing
my Knights there to defend keep pushing
get my knight on a three or D - maybe
with check less than 3000 let's take it
like that
just stop that pond from moving he was
kind of scaring me
okay now all my opponents pieces are
mobile advanced this H pun keep going
stepladder no ok back to Turner 133 oh
my goodness 210 210 133 less than 10
minutes
okay so Grand Prix just run it
oh wow I should have just taken this
night first how many free pieces I
should have taken this pond first ah
okay we're gonna have to deal with the
give me the dark squares okay this could
be main very soon rook here doesn't work
pond takes
what's the plan do I even have one play
on the dark squares oh this is a
wonderful square now f6 there King is
stuck they're gonna have to give up by
the rook I think hook up and over
oh this bishops dead
he is dead
okay we're a queen h3 rook g3 I want to
keep that tension
I think rook here to just oh the Queen
gave itself up now this is opening up
rook here now probably just made stuff
now Rick g3 and take with my queen
let's give a check first let's go with
this just get rid of that pond ooh that
Bishop was ready to get my queen
get rid of this eight seconds
um they're down on time I thought I
didn't know if they'd resign 208 153 I'm
not making any ground on this guy I need
to be paired up but even if we're paired
up and I somehow win I don't know if
that would even be enough okay they're
going for okay no you know they're
getting kicked around I have a giant
Center and it's just getting bigger can
do that pawn push huge space advantage
opposite they're clean okay all my
pieces working in the center in the
center pawn takes next mates right here
actually this is a slick move I think
context I give check and when the knight
moves Queen here is there okay now these
bishops are going to be monsters big
monsters take that on the bishop or I'm
on the rook rook is trapped Bishop takes
Bishop take the rook give up their dark
square Bishop their King is in big
trouble just want to take here and then
promote get a new queen they didn't do
anything with their King side-pieces
knight in here
pawn push Queen here Knights trapped if
he takes the pawn let's take this Knight
and then March clean here next pawn
takes Queen check everything
giant giant bunch of pawns here giant
amount of pawns get these guys promoting
actually anything
there's no time no time this game isn't
gonna finish 173 228 173 17 games in 5
minutes 55 here's somebody who flies
this guy flies ok I'm up this pawn I'm
gonna hang on to it
a 6 stop B 5 castle and stop B 5
actually it wasn't even on a pin and
then win if they take this is not good
pin and when he's hit twice defended 0
tough situation to be in me the light
squares light square Bishop is going to
be a monster I take like this my rooks
there to defend just want to complete
development I could do it with the tempo
Bishop takes pawn is probably still
there on the Queen they're probably
going to resign yes back to tournament
to 28 whew
228 193 four minutes list and fire a
little less than 5 minutes
c5 can I get a quick strike at each to
somehow could that pull me back in quick
age to strike all right there Knights
getting kicked around I go he I take the
knight and then post up here they can't
castles easily there they're not taking
that piece back they weren't taking that
piece back here I might still want to go
here opposite the Queen there's some
stuff here
Knight moving actually he doesn't have a
great spot to go to right here to here
let's get on the newly opened B file my
age pawn down we can this King position
whereas I still keep everything nice and
solid for my King the Jean G&F pawns
around for
my king the Aged pond is battering ram
there's some potential pins that my
Konica walking to as soon as you take on
the square it's in a pin and I'll look
to pile up on it or get rid of pieces
that are defending on d4 okay I can do
this I take with check around the bishop
and I could still just take the bishop
ignore the threat of my queen
maybe think we're trying to maybe they
were spending some time there cuz they
were trying to do what exactly maybe
they're trying to take my queen they
didn't see it was check my knight is
hanging why was I thinking so long right
there bishop here next ship here to here
and then look for back rank mate just
take this they're not anytime they
resigned back determine 213 248 213 I
could only get one more game in for sure
only one more game in for sure this guy
is having a good tournament 188 okay I
mean this get that Queen I can't take
here I have Bishop g36 stuff Queen is
close to dead she does have f7 though
okay there might be takes in the night
here night here first I'm on the Queen
oh there's Queen check I got to do this
luckily that was there I give a check
first I want to probably missed that
here no matter what
rook f6 stop here so while my bishops
chase I don't have to deal with tonight
before I need King position my knight
isn't pinned my bishop well hang on okay
this is a problem let's back up repair
my structure pawn push okay King
position King position rook g1 do this
first
it's about pounds on dark place III look
here I do this pile up on that pond they
have to defend okay undermine this okay
look right in there if the rook leaves
from the defense of the bishop okay now
I have this and the Bishop rook takes
Bishop as a threat
I missed that and I could take the pawn
if King here and defend my rook let's
just do this give a check in advance
bunch of passed pawns now and these guys
get rolling check King here
let's go like this split pawns I want to
be able to get a queen very fast they
reside back determine 233 268 233 one
minute remaining can I hold on to second
they might just call this there's a
minute left but they might just end up
calling this right away 102
I need to like age two strikes or
something each pot attack it worked once
before VIP warzone
number two the second term and I
replayed him there was a buzzer-beater
there was a buzzer-beater
I can't even move my pieces Queen h4
move Knight move somewhere okay move
he's trapped no he's not well the
Queen's are coming off
yeah material that's about it though
that is about it to drop back jump my
knight in here let's get some
development in finally Oh gonna blow out
that I missed that c3 move Forex might
be made mates right oh they got my
Brooke I got their Brooke it's hanging
out of mine rook you're gonna call this
it seems like I should have been called
it says it's completed smash through
here
it should be called by now take that
pawn and then take on each for there
they just called it what do we get
second or third second somebody was
right on my tail
also that third place guy 288 233 229
220
oh my goodness what was this guy eating
all right
good games oh wow okay